well Android doesn't work so well and
the purpose behind this will be to then
maybe think about the cases for it might
not work so well in the moment and how
to fix it I should also say ahead of
time that this is not gonna be about an
implemented system it's about a concept
that I think is fairly promising but has
not been empirically tested yet all
right so if you read the news and I
think one of the most striking
applications of machine learning
well not quite there yet but might be
there in the next five to ten years this
self-driving cars similarly you might
read about autonomous drones you might
also see that machine translation has
gotten really good quite recently
sometimes as you can see here even from
from images from cameras or from videos
text-to-speech isn't quite there yet but
it's super super promising and people
expect it'll be really good in the next
year or two as well and autocomplete on
Google is quite good as well even if it
doesn't quite ascertain our intentions
all the time
Netflix has pretty good recommendations
right you go there refresh the page and
it recommends movies that you might like
similarly Facebook is trying to show you
things in your feed that you might click
on that you might spend time on and if
you look at games there we often have
superhuman performance by now so for go
I think we're there and in the case of
the spear machine learning does work I
think it's a pretty great thing right
it's really fast on Netflix you just
refresh the page you don't have to wait
for a human to get back to you with
recommendations it's really cheap much
cheaper than human labor it's always on
you don't have a human who has to sleep
some of the time it's continually
improving so data sets grow and their
statuses grow your your systems get
better some cases it's superhuman
in all cases obviously it's very
scalable so you can have single system
that it's useful for hundreds of
thousands of people now I want to
consider some other tasks where it's on
the face of it not really clear how to
apply machine learning at the moment
probably I would classify those as tasks
of thinking or deliberation like suppose
you're trying to think about well how
can I find a girlfriend
friend and you're considering different
options maybe we should do online dating
or maybe I should go to bars but you
don't know what can we're learning
somehow help you there similarly maybe
you're thinking how can I be happier in
my life
in general it's kind of this fake
question look here that Michigan can do
anything for that or maybe you're
thinking how can I be healthier should I
go to the gym if I go to the gym what
should I do
should I eat differently what should I
eat or maybe you're thinking about
immigration how can I become legal yes
citizen you might think about how to get
a better job or how to get more pay at
your current job or maybe you're
thinking about more altruistic causes
like how can I personally do something
or global warming or can I do something
at all should I do something or
similarly maybe a thing about global
poverty is there something I can do
should I do something or US politics
it's like this extremely complex system
you're trying to think about well should
I get involved don't really know the
answer
so we up all these bake questions where
it's kind of hard to come up with good
answers and by weighing here I mean
questions that are not kind of factual
questions like what's the capital of
Germany or what's 86 degrees Fahrenheit
in Celsius I mean questions were really
your personal background kind of matters
so questions like what career is right
for me or how can I be healthier where
you can't just look up the answer and
get it in in a single response but there
has to usually be some back-and-forth so
how do we currently solve these sorts of
questions when I thought about it I did
this short list I think there are
probably other strategies that we do
employ but one thing we might do is we
might ask our friends and family right
so that's pretty useful because they do
know our background and so I can ask
someone hey do you know a job maybe just
startup that I could take instead of
being a post dog and they might have an
answer or we might consult experts like
if you're thinking about immigration you
might go to a lawyer and they might
might help us with that and they do have
very deep to my knowledge or if you
don't want to pay for a lawyer maybe
we'll just like read on the Internet
through immigration forums to get better
information about the question that
we're wondering
that's pretty useful too because there
is a lot on the internet obviously or
maybe just sit down and think because
unlike machine learning algorithms we
actually have human level reasoning
ability which also tends to be useful
and but all of these have drawbacks to
some extent right like if you ask our
friends and family they tend to have
limited knowledge they they don't know
in depth how immigration law works for
example we can consult experts but that
is a lot of overhead so I takes a lot of
time to make an appointment and they
also tend to be expensive and for some
topics they don't even really exist we
can search the internet but there's a
lot on the internet so it takes a lot of
time to find the things that are most
useful and some of the information on
the internet I've heard is also not high
quality and we might you know try to
just sit down and think for ourselves
but it's just difficult so we have these
different approaches to solving these
problems and they tend to have
complementary strings so I talked in the
beginning a little bit of machine
learning and how it's fast and cheap
always on and that's really great and
then we have people who like maybe they
know our personal background maybe they
have like human level reasoning ability
about deepen my knowledge can use Google
and other external tools and so on so
the question I want to consider today is
can we somehow integrate these two
sources to answer awake questions and if
you think about thinking about answering
such great questions and I think natural
language is generally among our most
powerful tools right like I personally
find it really useful you just make
notes for myself as I try to think
through any topic like writing down
relevant considerations one way or
another things to think about in the
future structuring my thought process
and similarly like talking to other
people is really useful and people who
might know things that I haven't
considered or might just help me think
through things even if they don't
contribute new evidence and that doesn't
have to be in person right like it can
also be like a conversation by texts or
by email so to make the problem of
answering the questions entirely
concrete I want to consider it specific
interface say on your phone like let's
say it looks something like this
let's say it's an app or you can either
enter a break question yourself or you
can pick one of an existing number of
topics like in this example like I'm
feeling crappy how can I feel better or
what phone should I buy two such
examples if you start a conversation by
clicking on any of these then you may
land on a screen that looks like this so
that's a conversation as a particular
topic here in this case how can I
improve my mood right now and the tasks
that we would need to solve to do better
here is to build something that can send
responses that go into this dialogue and
that are helpful so responses like this
like let's look it up let's look at some
potential causes have you have yet
enough sleep might be two such responses
and then on the bottom maybe there are
similar to the choice questions that we
can respond to or maybe it's just a
free-form response so how can you build
a back-end for this sort of front-end
interface like in particularly how can
we build one that makes use of human
ingenuity but also machine learning so
that's that's the high level goal for
this talk at the top of our roadmap to
integrate machine learning and people to
similar answer vague questions so the
structure of the talk is as follows I'll
first think about about dialog
automation using machine learning
ignoring people and then introduce the
system that I've been thinking about
again this concept has not been proven
empirically yet and then you find that
it's useful to think a little bit more
about how crowdsourcing works and
finally I'll have some words on what
what if this actually works what does
the world look like for both of the
intermediate sections I'll follow the
same kind of structure where I first
talked a little bit about what existing
approaches look like percent one
challenge that I think that was posed
and then I'll present an alternative all
right let's get started let's first
think about 'dialogue automation and
existing approaches there there's a big
field I definitely won't be able to
cover all of it but help to give some
intuition for what existing systems
might
clack so broadly in Delaware emission
the goal obviously is to have human-like
conversations but there are two broad
categories one is it's called directed
conversations like if you're trying to
book say your hotel or make a flight
reservation call your call your airline
then that's a goal-directed conversation
where the goal is to satisfy whatever
the customer has in mind and there the
conversations tend to be pretty
restricted like there's a specific
domain and you only have to take into
account some considerations not
everything on the other hand there are
more open-ended conversations often
people refer to those as chat BOTS and
there the goal really often is just to
be as human-like as possible and
sometimes to pass the Turing test
although that is not always explicitly
stated goal so I'll primarily talk about
the second category although in some
sense the goal that we have in mind for
this talk is a combination of the two so
let's look at what the performance of
those systems looks like I think until
recently and I don't know the history
too well but maybe until two or three
years ago the performance of these
systems was really not very good at all
and I'll show you one of the better
systems so it's clever but like the
human might have a conversation that
says with are you follower or a leader
and cleverbot might say no you might say
my name is David what is my name
Claire what might respond how old are
you David it's very pretty good that I
get the name right although it's not
like the best response by any means you
might say my name is John where's my
name there what says John pretty good
was the purpose of being intelligent but
says the purpose of life is to love God
and love people it seems kind of like a
canned response not quite appropriate
humans as the sky blue or black clever
what says I'm 200 years old yep not good
I think since since then things have
changed a little bit and especially with
BOTS that have been trained on large
data sets and then used neural Nets
things have gotten quite a bit better so
now I think systems have like extremely
basic reasoning ability so
but again try the prompt that we just
saw upper humans as my name is David was
my name as before machine now gets it
right says David are you leader or a
follower no disparo says I'm a leader so
it correctly like god this is a choice
between it's two things that picked one
and gave a grammatical response was the
color of a yellow car yellow that's
pretty impressive actually how much is
two plus two four other pretty good oops
geez and what is ten minus 272 not so
good so you can see like it can do
things that it can learn by parent
matching on a large corpus of data but
it can't really do any any deep
reasoning it does have some basic broad
knowledge just based on all the existing
dialogues it's been trained on so for
example a human right say or you think
about Tesla machine says he's a good
conductor well they don't rent kind of
wrong but in an interesting way what do
you think about Bill Gates he's a good
man
arguably that one works what do you
think about Messi he's a great player
it's pretty impressive what do you think
about Cleopatra her she's very regal
nice what do you think about England
during the reign of Elizabeth it was a
great place I think that is pretty
pretty amazing that it works as much as
a desk but you'll find that if you have
long conversations with surf spots they
don't have a lot of consistency like you
might I ask the system boys your job
maybe it says I'm a lawyer when you ask
what do you do it says I'm a doctor so
it's pretty clear that there's no
coherent world model beyond these
conversations it's just like some
learned pattern matching based a large
corpus with only a very small amount of
generalization our talk in a little bit
more detail about how these systems work
but before I got it there I want to
briefly review
supervised learning so in supervised
learning the approach generally is the
following
you start by defining some model space
either of functions or of conditional
distributions for example the space of
linear functions with some noise so that
means you have like some big cloud of
potential functions that you might want
to learn and your goal is going to be
one of them based on your training set
so you have some training set of pairs
of inputs to your function or
conditional distribution and outputs so
in the linear regression case it might
look like this input 1 output 3 input to
output 5 and so on and now your goal is
to fit the power rameters of the
function or conditional distribution
that you're trying to learn to maximize
the probability of that training set if
you do that for the for the regression
case you might find that well there's
one on the on one function in this big
space that works better than the others
and maybe it's in this case why cause 1
+ 2 X so you've soft your training
problem here and because we've done that
you can now use to learn function to do
prediction right so if you get a new
input example say you get a new input 4
you can now get a distribution or a
function output for that example so you
might say well now that I know that my
function is 1 plus 2x I can say y equals
1 plus 2 times 4 so my predicted output
is 9 this is a very simple example that
I'm giving here but I think the the same
principle applies to much more complex
examples you might say that instead of
using just linear functions for your
model space not going to be in neural
networks where the parameter instead of
just being a bias etc for the linear
case is now either weights of euronet
and then the training data I guess in
our case it would be something like
transcripts and responses for various
dialogues so like a transcript so far
and the next response based on dialogues
that humans have had again as before you
would fit the parameters of your neural
net to maximize the the protégée of your
data set and that would require you to
do some encoding of the data set and
then what you can do once you've trained
picked a particular instantiation of the
parameters and that's a political neural
net what you can do is you can give a
new transcript to the neural net and get
a predicted response for an input that
you haven't seen that wasn't part of
your training set all right
so what's what's the structure of these
neural nets in general and on a very
high level they tend to be some sorts of
recurrent neural nets where over the
course of dialogue the application might
look something exists though there's
some internal state which for neural
nets tends to be some opaque vector and
that internal state gets updated over
time based on the inputs I'm leaving out
a lot of details here but you can
generally think about little dots here
as factors and the arrows or
combinations of arrows in some cases as
neural nets that process these vectors
based on the previous state at each
point in time and also based on the
input once you define such a structured
function you can then train it on a
large corpus so you might have say a
thousand to 1 million dialogues that you
collected from humans and then you fit
the powers of your neural net to
maximize the probability of those
exactly those dialogues so this is
pretty good and that's the sort of
system that gave rise to the dialogues
that I showed you earlier the slightly
more impressive ones my cleverbot but it
does have some drawbacks as well though
in particular because the thing it's
trying to do is it's trying to give you
the most probable response at every
point in time you have to wonder is the
most probable response really the thing
you want and I think often often it's
not like often you have some dialogues
so far and the most probable thing for
the system to say it's just something
generic like I don't know I don't know
what you're talking about
just because those apply across very
many contexts another another issue here
is because the system doesn't do it like
any look-ahead might if you get two
loops like so here maybe you start the
dialogue as a human Basking the system
how old are you a system responds I'm
sixteen and now you're just gonna feed
the system's responses back into itself
just to see where it goes
system asks sixteen customer arc and
then system response again I don't know
what you're talking about
systems this you don't know what you're
saying system says I don't know what
you're talking about systems you don't
know what you're saying and so it's in
this
through because it just tries to predict
the next thing to say only very recently
people have tried to address this and
one way you can try to address this is
by combining surprised learning and
reinforcement learning and as SDS in
deep reinforcement learning so just two
very people to cover this you might
start in exactly the same way maybe
started before so you have your neural
net you train it on some large data set
using supervised learning but then you
don't stop there but instead you just
say well ok no if some initial parameter
set and now I'm gonna work work with it
and fine-tune it in some way and the
work the way you might want to find unit
is you define some reward function
there's a function of an entire dialog
so not just of a like single pair of a
transcript in a response but of a longer
longer sequence back and forth there's a
tricky problem of course because the
real like really this function to get it
right you won't want it to capture human
judgment about how good how natural this
dialogue is and so any heuristic you can
actually compute from the data is going
to not be quite appropriate but turns
out in practice doing things like
capturing semantic coherence is
something that can can be useful so if
you find some reward function that takes
in a dialogue and returns a number that
says how good this dialogue is and what
do you then is you take your system and
you simulate many dialogues between the
system and itself and at the end of
every dialogue you update the parameters
of your system neural net to make
dialogues that result in high scores
more likely and dialogues that result in
low scores less likely you might have
noticed that is exactly the same thing
that alphago is doing if you if you know
anything about the implementation of
that alright so that is I think among
the most advanced approaches to dialog
automation at the moment let's think
about like how far can this go is this
gonna solve the dialogue for the kinds
of questions were interested in these
sorts of break questions that require
reasoning and I think it's pretty easy
to see that there's serious challenges
here again like you're in the setting of
superest learning and I guess it's also
true for
learning here is that the data that we
ultimately have to learn from these
pairs of dialogues so far so partial
transcripts and next responses so maybe
here's the dialogue on where to go on
vacation which might be where should I
go on vacation is the first utterance
and then there's a response where do you
live
and maybe you have another in sensation
of this that where the dialogue is
preceded a little further or another one
so you have these collections of partial
dialogues and responses and that's our
data set and the tasks that our machine
learning system now has to solve it is
it needs to learn the function f that is
between those perfect dialogues and the
next responses this is of course an
extremely difficult problem because what
you need to learn here is not just to
understand language from scratch but
also to reason about the world and the
content of those dialogues so I think
this sort of problem of remote
supervision is particularly challenging
if you're in the setting of these sort
of vague dialogues where you're talking
like the intention is for you to talk to
someone who actually thinks about what
they're saying maybe they're considering
different things they might say to you
next or maybe they're taking into
account different considerations maybe
they're even looking at the definition
trying to reason through the things you
said and all of those kind of mental
steps that happened between the dialogue
and the next response are invisible
you're supposed to just learn them from
these pairs of a transcript in the next
sentence so that's really hard so I want
to think about how we can help address
this problem of remote supervision I
think one when inspiration here is to
think about our human thinking proceeds
and I guess we covered this a little bit
in the beginning but like writing down
notes is a really useful thing in many
many situations for example if you
consider a doctor there I think one
thing that it's known to be very useful
are checklists right like if you go to a
doctor you have a conversation where
they're trying to help you trying to
think through what are or your symptoms
what diseases might be compatible with
that what should they recommend then for
them to write down some of the things
that you say write down some of the
things
that they're considering addressing in
the future and maybe also going through
axillary information like checklists is
quite useful similarly if you're talking
to a therapist they might make some
notes about what you said things they
want to talk to you about in the future
and that can help them structure their
thinking as well so this intuition of
using notes to organize thoughts is what
I want to work with where the notes
again they capture key pieces of
information things to discuss things to
investigate in the future and maybe
templates and checklists that like a
person has learned are very useful right
like if if you were in the position of a
doctor or therapist and you had your
first conversation probably the notes
you would write down would not be quite
like that ideal no it's because you
don't know or the things that really
matter you don't have a schema for how
to talk to the person but after you've
had say a hundred or a thousand such
conversations you'll be really good at
this because you know how to have those
conversations worked things that the
person says matter of what things don't
matter and how do you think about the
kinds of topics that you're discussing
to give another very concrete example of
this like suppose you're trying to help
Bob find a girlfriend to resume the
topic from the very beginning you might
start by making some notes about the
general background of Bob maybe he's
like 16 to 20 years old very lives what
he does and so on as he talked about
some more he might find that you learn
about his prior experience in
relationships or with dating and your
structure that information so in general
I guess when I think about these notes
I'll be thinking about these sorts of
tree structured outlines but there's no
reason in general to constrain it to
that representation I just find it it's
a C useful and representation do you
think about and then you might have like
really long no it's very add more and
more information about things you want
to talk to Bob about etcetera etcetera
so that's the kind of intuition I want
and to work with where you'll similarly
want to think about like machine
learning systems that have some sort of
natural language workspace that they
operate on where they don't at each
point in time directly have the task of
coming up with an utterance to send to
the user or the dialogue partner but
instead
they need to choose what I would call a
cognitive action like to make some
change to their workspace and only
occasionally they might send something
to the the person they're talking to the
reasoning behind this is if you have
these intermediate steps you might be
able to get more fine-grained
supervision like more insight into what
is the system doing between what runs in
the next and maybe also you might be
able to provide some supervision on the
actual reasoning steps that are
happening okay let's walk through one
example let's look at the kind of where
should I go on vacation dialog so here
let me just explain the diagram that I
have here so in the bottom I have in the
field workspace just gonna be empty over
time it's gonna be some sort of outline
we have the superest learner which I
think we can assume is some sort of
neural net although it doesn't just need
to be and the task of the superest
learner is to take the workspace at
previous point in time and return the
action that it brings to be useful at
some point in time though not at all of
them will also get utterances from the
user which we can take to be just added
directly to the workspace and that then
results in workspace in the next point
in time all right
so let's walk through this over the
course of time a little bit so you start
with an empty workspace and maybe your
learner has learned and we'll talk about
how that learning might work that if the
workspace is empty it's best you just
wait until something is at it then at
some point
Ellis gives our initial question we're
sure you're on vacation it gets added to
the workspace and now it contains Ellis
whether I go on vacation now the system
might take a very small step from there
where it just rewrites the thing that
get added to the workspace a tiny bit
into the sort of root level question
bear Fidelis convocation which is gonna
be the thing that the system is going to
try and help with then before sending
any any message back to Ellis the system
might add another another bit of
structure to the workspace where it says
okay well I've learned in the past
one thing that's useful to learn about
when I have been discussing that sort of
question is what is Salas background
similarly it might add another bit that
says like what options are there what
what options for where to go on vacation
so all of this is happening without any
information being sent to Ellis is all
just internal and information
organization and then at this point the
system might actually send a message to
Ellis so the way I'm implanting it here
is by tagging message with Ellis
although there's other ways of
implanting that so the system adds this
message where do you live at Ellis to
the workspace and it gets sent as an
output to Ellis system knows when I add
such a thing to the workspace it's
usually good to wait so deaths at some
point Ellis says in San Francisco and it
gets added to the workspace and so it
continues maybe the system at this point
as a small edit where it rewrites the
pair of where you live at Ellis Ellison
and we're just going a slightly shorter
form as Ellis lives in San Francisco and
so on I think the really important thing
to note here is these workspaces are
human readable and what that makes
possible is very fine-grained human
support so a human contributor might at
any point in time
go in and make a change to the workspace
so if you notice that the system is not
representing an important information or
structuring the information in a way
that doesn't make sense a human could go
in and could change it
similarly the machine learning system
might learn to post questions to the
workspace so you might you might not
want to train your neural net to do
calculation for example like suppose
you're having some dialogues that you
require you to multiply large numbers
and it may be better for the system to
just post the question what is 123 times
4 17 to the workspace and then wait for
another system to post the response then
for you to directly train your neural
net to do that calculation so the video
game that we're trying to play here is
that of decomposing a program in the
parts that machine learning can
and all parts that other systems like
calculators or knowledge bases can
handle and parts that only human cannon
humans can handle let me give you one
more example of how such integration
with other systems might look like
I suppose you're back in the setting
where we have the dialogue on where
Fidelis convocation and we have the sub
question where a cell is lived now our
system might have learned that one
useful thing to ask here is what is else
IP address and maybe then there's some
other system like some web bought that
can actually look up at least IP address
and can add the answer to the workspace
at that point in time our system might
ask was the location for the IP address
and maybe there's a third system that
can only do one thing which is like
answer questions of the form what is the
location for that IP address and that
then adds the answer to that question
and now our system can have do the
information processing to like gather
together those two responses into a
short sentence based on IP address Ellis
lives in San Francisco so we get an
educated guess for the answer to the
customer as Ellis lived without
explicitly asking Ellis just through the
use of some other external systems all
right so here I kind of just assumed
that our system is trained already we
have class well how how do we train a
system like that how do we learn that
and one obvious answer is well let's
play the supervised learning game we'll
gather data on the forum workspace in
the next section and each point in time
presumably from from humans for the most
part and then we'll learn a function
that map's workspace to a next section
here next section again is something
like adding a node to the workspace
moving something editing something
deleting something pertinent together
with some necessary data like what's the
text that we're adding or what's the
identity of the node where we're
changing I want to go into too much
detail on what exactly the functions
here might look like but it's quite
similar to the neural net setting that
that I'd brought up before where maybe
the function
the neural net that is kind of like the
neural nets are used for translation
where you have an encoder and a decoder
so maybe anchored that instead of taking
a sequence of words it takes a tree and
codes it into a vector representation
and then by using an iron and decodes it
into an action to take maybe it also
uses attention mechanisms I think
there's a lot of interesting work to be
done here and just trying out different
sorts of learners but over overall the
hope is that this function from work
space to next action is somewhat easier
to learn than the function from dialogue
so far - next utterance because the
steps are smaller and it's there's more
more supervision on what is happening in
between
alright so that's that's our approach to
dialogue automation will learn these
sorts of the little cognate actions on a
burg space that is shared with human
contributors now let me talk about like
how to like turn that into a more
complete system like the kind of thing
that you could actually plug into like
the little app interface that I showed
you earlier so that we have one part
which is our main dialogue spurring
these connections but then the question
is hug how do you actually get the
training data right like why would
anyone contribute data to this it's
pretty important to point out that
unlike existing dialogue automation
systems we are in the setting where
there is basically no existing training
data because we can't at least not
directly train on existing dialogues we
have this other data that we want and we
need workspaces and next sections so
this needs to become needs to come from
somewhere so the answer that I want to
consider here is that we set up a market
for both human and also automated
contributions to that workspace where
essentially we pay people to provide
that information so concretely again if
you go back to our app isn't we have two
kinds of users we have people who are
asking these sorts of white Christians
and then we have people who are doing
some thinking or who are domain experts
for people are asking questions before
you seen the interface before I'll make
one slight change here
yes well to slight changes one is I'll
add a link to the workspace if people
want to not just see their dialogue but
also the kind of hidden things that are
going on under the hood and the other
maybe more significant changes that I'll
also add an option for people to pledge
rewards towards the resolution of the
right big questions so if someone has a
question that they really care about a
lot they might put up ten or hundred
dollars and that will fund contributions
to the corresponding workspace so
abstractly that's what it looks like if
I ask her maybe they use an app on their
phone we have some dialogue market
server those two exchange both messages
and also rewards for thinkers and
experts we can consider having some part
of that web interface know maybe the way
it works is there is a list of questions
that people post that people can browse
so maybe they can sort those questions
by the most recent ones there was one
Smith was mr. Ward there was with the
fuse contribution so far or by topic
they might look at any particular
dialogue see well how many contributions
have there been so far how much has been
pledged when was it traded and then
experts or thing as can pick one of
those to contribute to if they like if
they click on any of those so maybe I'll
click on the one I'm highlighting here
then I might come to interface that
looks like this where again there's a
title and the word but then there's also
the dialogue on the right and that is
exactly the same thing that we saw in a
little mobile app interface before but
on the Left there's a burg space so
that's the same thing I was showing on
the kind of sequential attempt serious
neural net illustration so that might
contain parts where the both thoughts
and also the thinkers are just thinking
through potential considerations that
might be important like in this case
where someone is trying to figure out
why why they're in a bad mood that
people might think well what are
causes probate mood maybe its lack of
sleep links or stifling hungry and so on
all that might contain parts that are
actually visible to the person that the
system has has a dialog if so things
like this where appear warning well what
is my situation of the Oscar like and
then there again these tagged responses
where you say oh oh let's first look at
potential causes at Oscar before we had
at Ellis have you had enough sleep at
Oscar maybe provide some what other
choice responses and then we might get a
response from from the asker here I'm
also doing another little bit of
indirection we're in self directly
sending responses to the Oscar I have
this extra intermediate step where
people are BOTS can vote on which my
response to sent next but I think that's
not a critical ingredient alright so
besides the Oscar we have these other
participants in our system the human
contributors human thinkers and experts
and there's another third group of users
that is kind of filling exactly the same
role as the human think of as next
person every programmer so writing BOTS
and just like a human thinker expert can
make some money by participating in the
system the thought is that a programmer
can also write a bot that then if the
bot does useful things will earn some
money for the programmer I think there's
really nice synergy between ten for this
market idea and this dialogue automation
idea because obviously the market in
centralizes contributions and so you
have a way of getting training data but
even beyond that the market also
incentivizes the creation of parts so in
some times you might not even want to
start with the dialog automation system
you might just want to start with this
sort of perk space and the market around
contributions and then people might
build BOTS may more interestingly
once you have such payments you can use
them as reward signals for reinforcement
learning algorithms so you're no longer
constrained to the supervised learning
setting
but there's a problem just you have
these rewards say $10 and now you have
all these little contributions on the
left what do you do with the world right
like who gets how much reward seems like
a critical issue to resolve and to think
about this a little bit more clearly I
want to look into crowdsourcing and the
way people tend to do crowdsourcing
these days so I think to my knowledge
most of crowdsourcing is happening on
Amazon Mechanical Turk where people can
post tasks and then human workers can
post responses and make small amounts of
money so the tens of tasks you might
find there are things like ordering
translations by quality so you went on
the left you might get some furniture in
your sentence this on the right you get
potential translations and now you're
supposed to if you're Chinese speaker
you're supposed to order those or
another another task you might find on
Mechanical Turk is describing movie
scenes so there's a movie that's playing
on the page and you can highlight
different periods in the movie and
describe what is going on there I think
both of these are used to train machine
learning algorithms actually or or to
evaluate those another task is very
common is something like finding the
email or of a business or looking up the
email the email so something very people
get the name and maybe sometimes the
website of a business and then they need
to like look on the internet and find
like the corresponding information so
much some other tasks you might find
there are things like labeling images
like what was shown on this image which
kinds of objects on the image are
identifying which kinds of product
reviews are real and which are fake or
transcribing short audio clips if you
look at these tasks and then one thing
they all have in common is their micro
tasks so they all tend to be very short
like they can be done on the met on the
order of seconds and sometimes minutes
but another another thing they have in
common is
that they tend to have mostly fixed
rewards so well there's some tasks where
you can earn bonuses if you do prickly
well for the most part that doesn't play
a big role
so human labor here is kind of treated
as a commodity and like the contribution
by one Turker is as good as its won by
another now let's let's consider some
other potential tasks you might want to
put up on Mechanical Turk or tests where
you might want to distribute rewards
yeah here you're obviously the intention
will be to then go back to the dialog
setting and think about the tasks as the
contributions to a workspace so here's
here's one thing that would be fun to do
like suppose there's some Wikipedia
article maybe on micro work here in this
case and suppose it's quite bad it's
like only a single sentence but you care
about it being a lot better like maybe
at the moment it looks like this but you
want it to look like this with many
sections and teacher discussion of what
micro work is how can you make that
happen suppose the way you want to make
it happen is you say well okay I'm gonna
touch a hundred dollars towards the
improvement of this PG PD article and
then at the end of this month I'm gonna
look at everyone who contributed by
everyone in the Wikipedia community who
made a change to this article and
there's probably gonna be many changes
and then I'm gonna reward them of course
then you face exactly the same problem
is in the dialog setting which is how do
you distribute those hundred dollars
over these contributions like some of
them are just going to be fixes to type
OS others are going to be like editions
of entire new sections again others
might just be vandalism so you're
probably almost certainly you don't want
to just uniformly distribute your money
or these contributions I think there's
quite quite a few settings there like
this so another another case that is
similar to this is suppose your
repository on github with some code and
you would like to reward people who
commit code to that repository that
further it's whatever goals you have for
your code
you face a similar issue where some
commits are really useful others are
just like minor minor help and again
others are actually harmful or maybe you
have a Google Talk and you're trying to
brainstorm some topic maybe where to go
on vacation or something more important
and the people who are participating in
your brainstorming they can see the
previous suggestions there too there's
this issue of how useful is a particular
contribution like sometimes someone
really has a big insight and sometimes
it's something a person suggests is just
a small variation on something that's
already there maybe you're trying to
outsource a logo design and you're one
of those pages where people can see
previous logo designs I think that is
actually a real a real issue where if
you go to one of those lower contest
sites and the designers who are
participating contributing their logos
can see the previous designs and
sometimes it happens that I think
someone's have been to logo and it's not
like it's a pretty good idea it's not
quite what you want someone else submits
a small improvement on it and the small
improvement wins and the person who like
didn't of the work doesn't get anything
or you might want to outsource
contributions to one of those dialogue
workspaces to facilitate answering vague
questions so what all of these tasks
have in common is that they have these
highly variable and like values and not
just that but they're also uncertainly
if you look at any particular edit to
your Wikipedia page it's not really
clear what the reward should be hard
hard to tell the thing that makes this a
real problem is that you do want to pay
in proportion to how helpful that task
is like if you don't do this then you're
not going to incentivize the most
helpful contributions because people are
just gonna like make some changes
knowing that they'll get rewarded either
way but you can't easily pay in
proportionally up for the task is
because evaluating a task is so
expensive in your time so the overhead
of a relation might easily be bigger
than the value of the task itself so
yeah we have this problem where we can't
evaluate our contributions but we'll
need to do is somehow choose a
proxy for the reward that tells us what
to pay for any particular contribution
but we need some condition to hold that
is something like the expected reward
for any contribution is still the true
reward that we would end up with if you
did a deep expensive evaluation if I
think maybe made this not possible at
all maybe there's just no economically
feasible way of doing this but one way
to see that this is not true
is to look at the following strategy of
randomized evaluation so suppose what
you do for each task is you just say
well I'm gonna avoid with some small
probability let's say it's one in a
hundred and only if like a flip a coin
it comes up heads which happens one out
of a hundred times I'm gonna evaluate
the task and decide what I would reward
I should pay for it but then if you just
get evaluated I'm gonna scale up their
board by a hundred so if I would
otherwise pay a dollar I'm gonna pay
hundred dollars if it does not get
evaluated I'm gonna pay nothing this
strategy has an expectation the correct
payments so that's good but at the same
time there's extremely high variance
people are not gonna like that 99 over a
hundred times you're not gonna get paid
anything right I think it's still like
too interesting that it is possible to
have a strategy that has correct
payments and expectation because it
shows that our goal here is kind of to
reduce the variance of the payments and
without introducing bias or without
increasing a lot of bias so here's a
variation on this strategy that you
could pursue we've seen supervised
learning before and you might notice
that we're been very evaluating a few
tasks and only looking at though it's
not looking at all of the tasks we're
kind of in the supervised learning
setting right because we have data for
for some things don't have data for the
others what if you try to predict data
for the others so here's a strategy that
you could follow is you could evaluate a
fraction of all the tasks that you get
and because that fraction is potentially
quite small you might be able to spend a
lot of time on each of those tasks now
you have data of the firm task and
reward that you listed it and you can
just pay for those particular tasks did
you deliver it exactly the reward that
you got but then you for these other
tasks and you didn't evaluate so here
the pro strategy would be well may you
just predict the rewards for an animal
or the tasks I think there's many
possible features that you could use as
inputs into your prediction right like
particular I think metadata is is a good
candidate here we're like the task
author is often really informative like
the same person tends to make good
contribution or tends to make bad
contributions across time you might look
at the history of rewards of a
particular contributor or you might look
at maybe judgments by other participants
maybe your system includes like some
form of downloading or uploading and
there is particular participants who
have really good judgment whenever they
upload something or download something
it's really predictive of whether you're
going to like it or not so that's the
baseline strategy that you could follow
I think there's a lot of complications
here but I think they can be addressed I
want to go into a few of those because I
think they're actually quite interesting
for their own sake independent of the
dialog setting so a first complication
is if I ask you well I want you to
evaluate this particular contribution
like this particular edit to your
Wikipedia page and say and tell me like
how much you want to pay for this there
might be just a really hard question to
answer right like even if you give even
if I give you a lot of time like an hour
or two hours it might just be hard to
come up with like a good a good number
there the one thing I don't think I can
do is I can ask you many more questions
to ask you things like which off which
of the tasks which of the edits to your
Wikipedia page save are most helpful to
you which will look like they're least
helpful was this particular task more
helpful than this other task if you had
to group these tasks somehow like what
bigger group with the particular task
here belong to
how helpful was this entire group and so
on you can think about a lot of
questions but the important point is
like if I ask you many like for answers
to many such questions then if I define
a formal semantics for each of those I
can use automated inference to infer
like what kind of reward is consistent
with that that set of answers I might
just take that or then at face value or
maybe a short you and ask you well does
that reward seem right does it try to
low so that that is about doing deep
evaluation in the few cases very duty
into it another and the thing is you
might be right about is in the cases
where we don't do deep evaluation maybe
the task features are just not enough to
make good predictions right like maybe
you just can't take the author's
identity and a bunch of other features
to predict the rewards with any
confidence there I think one useful
thing to do is to reward predictive
signals like if you have that person as
before that I mentioned that always
avoids things that you end up liking
maybe they should get part of the reward
or maybe the way you make such a person
exists is by having a system that pays
signals that help you if effectively
decide which things mmm to give high
reward with you without you having to
devaluation a third problem might be
that I guess plain terms people will try
to cheat if you use some features to
predict rewards like say you've learnt
that whenever people from Cambridge
write something on your page it tends to
be really good and just to get high
reward then people will start saying
they're from Cambridge even if they're
not there I think to some extent is just
a hard problem and I think there are
some machine learning algorithms in
Wicklow online learning that could help
a little bit but the other thing that
could help here is also rewarding
predictive signals so some signals are
going to deteriorate under market
pressures but then there are others like
the uploads by the helpful person that I
mentioned that might not because that
person might have incentive to keep them
predictive and then finally I think it's
just also the case that some tasks can
be valid in context right like India
example like suppose you see a
contribution that is a deletion like
someone deletes a sentence and there are
different reasons for why that could
happen like maybe they deleted it
because they want to replace it with a
better sentence or maybe they deleted it
because they don't like you and they
want to vandalize your page I mean
there's a lot that that can be done to
address that problem like you can
require people to like patch their
contributions into kind of semantically
meaningful parts like grouping deletions
and adds for example you can always
provide some context like previous and
following contributions when you're when
you're requiring someone to evaluate a
contribution or you can require people
to annotate and if people don't give
good justifications you can just skip
low reward so that's the basic strategy
that we'll be following for a reward
distribution we'll only evaluate a few
contributions in detail and we will use
machine learning predictor words for the
other contributions that we don't
evaluate so that's kind of the second
into ingredient into making the dialogue
market system work we learn to break
towards alright
we're very yet I started by talking
about deliberation so we have these
tasks where some of them are really
things that people care about a lot like
finding a partner that being happier
being healthier thinking about how they
can usefully contribute to the world
finding a better job and so on I talked
about how we might start to automate
deliberation by not directly learning to
automate dialogues not directly going to
predict the next responses given
transcripts so far but I looked at by
learning these four more Congress
actions on a workspace that is shared
with human contributors that of course
post poses a problem of how do you
incentivize human contributors to make
useful contributions to set your
workspace so we came up with this idea
of setting up a market for both human
and pod contributions to network space
but that also was challenging because
you now need to be able to tell how good
particular contributions are so that you
can distribute the reward
there's pledged towards a particular
conversation so we came up with this
additional idea of just predicting most
rewards and only doing deep evaluation
for a few contributions so that that's
the combination of those two ideas is
for what I call dialogue markets I think
there's another point of synergy that I
didn't mention before and that is pretty
important and it's that when you do deep
evaluation of a particular contribution
you can actually use the dialogue market
system itself right like that this
question how much should I pay for this
contribution its itself a weight
question like if what what is me and how
much should you pay it have hard but you
can try to think through it like think
through different considerations like
the kinds of triangulation questions I
mentioned before and that can happen for
dialogue and if you do that and you can
use the entire system like including
like the workspace is the crowdsourcing
the automation on a meta level I think
this is really nice because if that
works then like your reward distribution
will also improve over time making your
system work better and better so what
like what if photo of Miss works I guess
as I mentioned at the beginning like
this is not implemented yet this at the
moment just a concept that I think it's
promising but what what have you
actually succeed I think there will be
pretty great
I would allow us to kind of delegate
arbitrary problems of thinking like I
mentioned the example of how do i
improve my mood but really any kind of
question would fall under that and we
could delegate it by providing pre
minimal input ourselves we're delegating
as much of the thinking as possible
maybe would only occasionally respond
with these sorts of multiple-choice
responses we'd only be limited in in
this task in by how much we're willing
to pay for thinking on any particular
problem so in some sense you can think
of about the goal here as turning
thought into
commodity and I think like the the fact
that we does could leverage machine
learning to help people think it's
pretty important because then if this
really worked then over time as machine
learning algorithms get better and
better people would get better and
better support of thinking through these
questions do they care about a lot
thanks any questions is there assuming
that posture is even decidable but I
mean this you can figure out that
somebody's trying to come back and one
of the problems is you have outside back
channels so if you ask humans should we
ban X for interesting X's I can
guarantee I can you to a thousand ten
thousand a hundred thousand people to
say yes sort of independent of whatever
I try to come up with an example
somebody who to be bad my best ones
mother Teresa but I couldn't easily
think why would one might want to ban
Mother Teresa
so given that given the people are
trolls or list of some set of different
roles how can the action can deal with
that or but when the corruption signal
is much larger than the potential good
signal this the trolls are motivated
unlike in the case of Twitter there's no
kind of community that you're trying to
optimize but rather for any particular
dialogue any conversation you're trying
to optimize with respect to the values
of the particular person that you're
talking to so the problem to solve is
like not to globally decide do we ban X
but rather like for any dialogue if
there's a contribution it's something
that the person wants to be there or is
it something that they don't want to be
there that of course is also a
challenging trying task perhaps equally
challenging to the issue that you raised
I think they're the same strategies
apply as to reward distribution more
generally where you're just trying to
pick this is the person gonna want to
have the mother Teresa answer her
dialogue or not and if there are some
people who can give predicative signals
about what that person was to be there
maybe by uploading or downloading or
adding specific comments then you can
use those signals to make those
decisions